Enable the mic access for the
participants.
Okay.
S.
Good evening again.
Welcome all of you to this particular.
MTech Software Engineering Program,
as well as the course on AI Augmented
Software Development.
I hope my audio is clear.
In case if you have any issues in hearing
me,
you can type it in the chat or you can
also unmute yourself and you can.
Let me know.
So we will,
I'll just give a brief introduction about
the course, about the program, as well as.
..
The entire.
Semester structure, et cetera,
a quick brief, not more than a minute. So,
so first of all,
congratulations and welcome to this
particular program,
M Tech Software Engineering.
So I hope this will be your first
semester and first day of class.
So is this your second class or?
Sorry.
I think you would have had one of them
all.
Yes, Narasimhan.
Second class,
basically second class didn't happen
today, so this was the third one.
So I actually did a second one.
Okay, thanks.
Okay,
so you have three classes on Saturday and
you have one on the Sunday, is it?
Yeah.
Okay, great.
So we will have our session that is AI
Right.
Augmented Software Development Life Cycle
and 550 to 750 slot.
So before getting into the course,
so my name is AKSHAYA.
I work for the WILP CSIS department off
campus.
I am based out of Chennai.
I have been working with the WILP bits
for almost close to 10 years now.
I work as assistant professor.
So predominantly our role lies in
teaching, plus content development,
curriculum design, program structure, etc.
I also.
coordinate programs,
corporate partnership programs,
where we have some specific
collaborations whom we work with,
where the same kind of programs you have
enrolled for is offered to students of
certain corporates who wanted to continue
their education similar to you.
So I also coordinate
Such programs, so coming to courses.
So always my first preference and
priority has been teaching software
engineering related courses.
So I often teach MTech for MTech Software
Engineering.
So the courses I usually teach are mostly
on application development,
scalable services,
full Stack Application Development,
scalable services.
DevOps related courses.
I also work in areas.
on the design aspects that is user
experience design,
human computer interaction or human AI
interaction.
So these are normally the courses I teach.
Coming to this particular AI Augmented
SDLC.
So I think all of you would have
undergone a
program orientation where they would have
given you some insights about what is the
program about,
what are the courses involved.
So I was also part of the program design
team who had structured this particular
MTech Software Engineering program.
So one thing we had.
as a objective or as an idea when this
program was restructured. Basically,
it's not a new program. It existed.
It had run many iterations.
But we saw the transitioning happening.
And the transitioning a few years back
when we had restructured the program,
There was a different kind of
transitioning happening in the software
engineering as well as the software
development on a whole is when the DevOps
came into picture and when we had more of
full Stack developers come in and we
wanted
more of a agile plus a continuous
integration and a CICT pipeline.
So that was one time where we saw
considerably a number of changes has to
be brought to the program because it was
completely transitioning to a
More on a.
Different aspect,
but the recent transition when we had
designed this program is more on the.
AI acceleration which has been
contributing to it. So over the last two,
2 1/2 years, we had.
slightly modified many of our courses
matching the industry needs because we
saw that, for example,
I'll take the example as a full Stack
Application Development course,
which many of you might have elective in
the upcoming semesters.
So when we started this course, it was
The React was introduced and React itself
had undergone many versions, changes.
It was evolving.
But last 2 and half years,
we saw the AI being used
at every phase of not only development,
but every phase of software engineering
by different angles,
whatever was possible by different people,
whatever.
Tools and technologies were available.
And we saw how it is reshaping.
many things. And when it came to,
when it crossed the general large
language models and the general chat
based interfaces we have, the ChatGPT,
etc.
And when it went into the agent and
agentic world, we saw there was a lot of..
.
harness coming into it.
I think I'm using certain terminologies
which I'll be going into complete detail
in the later part of the course or
whenever I start my classes.
So the harness is like when you try to
build or control something which is
already existing, which has some power.
So many of our coding agents,
right from Cloud Code or Copilot,
they are all built harness around large
language models which are available.
So this,
when you say you are building something
or you are engineering something,
there itself an entire software
engineering comes into picture, right?
So we saw that when it comes to agent,
there is a lot of software engineering
involved. And the same.
Like one size doesn't fit all.
The same principle or same method which
we have been using to design our
applications did not fit into fit for the
ML based applications or agent based
applications or AI applications.
There had to be a few.
changes which has to be brought in.
So those are one kind of changes into
this program. But how do you also look at.
..
the entire software engineering aspect,
AI Augmented the software engineering
Development Life Cycle.
So there is SC for ML,
that is software engineering for ML
applications.
How do you software engineer?
So now this is AI for SC.
That is how can you use AI to do various
tasks which are for the software
engineering and that
That was the, when we looked at it,
we saw that there are so many avenues in
which AI can be used in software
development life cycle.
And we saw that there has been a
considerable number of research in this
particular area which has been going on.
Plus, we saw the industries also.
actually equipping itself to do.
And of course, there are a few challenges.
There are many major players who are
successful,
but there are many players who are still
in the change mode, etc. So,
so it's a very niche area, I would say,
but
We like the outputs which are coming from
LLM.
There are many non-deterministic ones as
well. But we will see how,
so our entire agenda for this course or
what we are going to look at from this
course is how AI can be applied to every
level of software development lifestyle.
But, so, basically...
We are looking at.
How products can be shipped back with the
with the every phase being followed with
improved productivity and using AI as an
accelerator,
and but when I say AI and we are using it,
we are not always so.
So you cannot,
I'm not going to blindly come and say
that we are going to use AI at all places.
We are going to also evaluate whether
inferential.
requirement is there.
If a simple static code analyzer can do a
thing at that place,
we are not going to go in for an...
inferential one,
a computational tool would fit in there.
So we are not only just going to look at
what AI is going to benefit us,
we are also going to evaluate whether AI
will fit at this space,
what are the challenges when AI is being
fit at this place.
in each phases.
So when it starts from right from
requirements to the deployment,
at each phase we are going to look at
what AI is going to do, what AI can,
what AI will benefit,
we will benefit out of it,
and what are the significant risks it is
going to bring in.
What are the solutions we have to tackle
or mitigate at that point in time?
So we are going to discuss all this in
this entire particular course.
So I've been asked to keep it very light
today because there will be a few more.
learners who will be joining.
So the core part, the module one,
I will start from next session,
but I just want to understand a few
things from all of you.
So what are the new AI buzzwords you have
heard recently?
You can type in chat.
A I related buzzwords. OK, MCP,
agentic workflow, anti-gravity.
LLM agents, OK.
Codex.
context engineering.
Agent K.T. K. Langchain open clock cursor,
Claude.
Token maxing, okay. Yeah.
Ethical AI.
AI skills.
Agent force. OK,
I'm just I'm just cutting down the
repeated ones and just going for the new
ones alone. OK, so agent force agent TKI.
context we have already heard.
Model routing, spec coding. Yeah,
I was expecting that spec coding or spec
driven Development. AGI. Yes, of course,
AGI. Distillation, OK. Shadow AI.
I wish I had this Mentimeter.
Mentimeter has, I think, a limitation.
And whatever goes to Mentimeter,
I'm not able to bring it back to the PPTs
again. That's why I didn't use it.
But I wish I had built a word cloud.
Maybe I will do it after the class and
share it all with you. Replit, token,
Replit N8N.
OK, then of loop engineering.
K.
Yeah, I need to.
Okay, wonderful.
So I was expecting one more thing.
Token maxing had come. So tokenomics,
that is token economics,
and I was also expecting harness
engineering. So these are also some terms.
Okay, so whatever.
Many of you have posted, we will be,
we will touch many of this in our course.
Of course, agents for sure, LLMs for sure,
prompt engineering for sure,
token maxing for sure.
The detail on how much we will go into it
depend on the module, etc.
So when you have the complete idea about
the module structure,
you will know how we are going to go into
detail of each of these words, etc.
Okay.
So my second question is,
I don't have the question.
What came to your mind when you first saw
the name of this particular course?
You can type, or if you want,
you can also unmute yourself and speak.
If many of you want to speak,
you have your hand raised,
so we can go in the order.
Yes, we'll go with the yeah.
Yes, ma'am.
So I think it is all about how we use AI
to augment the software development.
I mean,
in terms like all the phases of SDNC,
starting from requirement gathering,
then design, then coding, then use,
deployments, maintenance.
every phase of the operator development
life cycle,
how can we use AI or what are the AI
applications that we can do in each of
these areas, which can bring value to,
I mean, different ecosystems, right?
Whether it is a developer ecosystem or it
is the customer or it is maybe the
infrastructure people.
So,
how do we use AI to help the entire life
cycle bring more value efficiency speed
and all of that? So, yeah.
Yes.
Yeah, that's exactly right. I'm spot on.
Yes, yes, we'll hear from Abhinav,
then I'll go to the chat messages as well.
Good evening, ma'am. Am I audible?
Yeah, yes, you are.
Yeah, thank you for this opportunity.
Yeah, I go on, right? So, nowadays,
without AI, nothing happens,
and whether we are working for our
customers or internal projects,
everyone is chasing.
I know in which part of Software
Development Life Cycle we are bringing in
AI, and it has touched all the flow,
all the...
phases of it. So in fact,
when we are discussing on which course to
take and what are the syllabus of this
one,
I was honestly looking for areas where AI
has been introduced or AI has been,
you know, inducted, right?
And I found this course is there in the
first semester and then there are several
electives.
later which focuses on AI, then I thought,
yes,
this course is really modified to keep up
with the latest trends and this is 1 I
should go with. So that actually,
you know, inspired me.
I think this course and a few other AI
courses inspired me to opt for this
stream as my MT.
And thank you, Abhinav. Yes,
we'll go with Gurdeep Singh, yes.
Good evening, ma'am.
Yes, Gudino.
Hope I am audible.
Yes, you are.
Ma'am, like...
Stitching AI with Software Development
Life Cycle,
what I understand is like so far for
years,
the SDLC has always been revolving around,
you know, waterfall models.
And afterwards,
like after many years from 2012 onwards,
then we move to slowly move to agile.
models. Now with AI,
with AI coming into picture in big time,
so the timelines have reduced quite a lot.
Earlier with Waterfall,
it used to take years to develop a
software. With Agile,
it became slightly more streamlined and
the timelines reduced a bit.
But with AI, the timelines have disrupted.
It's a disruptive move with the
introduction of AI. So accordingly,
our software development life cycles need
to be adjusted according to the pace that
AI brings to, you know,
software development because the whatever,
for example, earlier it used to take.
like maybe minimum one year to go to the
market. With AI, it may be reduced to,
let's say, two or three months also.
So how to adapt to that change of pace?
I think that's why this topic,
it is going to discuss in that direction.
As per my my knowledge.
Yes.
Okay, right.
So I'll also look at the chat-based
questions. But before that,
in the meantime, I look at the chat.
I just want to give you all a simple poll.
I'm just initiating a poll,
so you'll get some a question then.
Few options.
I don't still have the split up of what
does each of you work in,
which I will collect it through.
A Google form or maybe a Ms.
forms shortly,
but this is just to have an initial idea.
I'm just launching a poll.
So you can put in your answers there.
Did you all get it?
Okay,
by the time everyone puts in the answer.
I'll go to the chat. So yes,
how can we improve productivity in each
phase? That's exactly right.
Chetan has mentioned that speeding up the
development. Guru RAJ has mentioned that,
yes, it's not only development,
all phases of software life cycle is what.
But the first thing all of us use
AI is for the development.
Agentic models is something which we
might not cover in detail.
We will use agents,
but we will not be developing any
particularly,
we will not get into the agentic aspects
of it.
uses of AI in every phase of development,
how we can automate SDLC,
that's exactly right,
to improve the workflows.
AI how to and how entire software
Development phase end to end is using AI.
That's exactly right.
And AI assisted architect design and
coding. That's also exactly right.
S.
Yes,
and VMP has been brought on traditional
process,
how it has evolved with AI tools at all
phases. That's exactly right.
So want to know where AI helps the most
in SDLC?
OK,
that there is no right answer for that.
OK, probably, or to be very frank,
I even don't know where it is the most
helpful,
but where it is actually adopted faster
and in practice I can give you some
numbers later in the in the upcoming
classes, but today I can tell you.
The initial parts,
that is requirements gathering when you
do want to collate few informations,
coding of enough testing.
And of course,
a few maintenance work is where it is
being adopted.
But where many of us are still not very
confident or many of the industries are
not ready to take the risk is on
believing it on the production ready
software.
So whenever you want to do a POC,
or MVP and share it with your internal
team or you want to pitch it to your
client.
I think almost in all phases they are
doing it,
but when they have to go and touch.
the legacy code or brownfield
developments or and you want to make it
more productionized.
We still are not 100% confident on what
is coming out of AI.
We are looking at ways and...
We are looking at ways in which the trust
can be improved.
We are also looking at ways in which we
can bring in the deterministic approach
from the non-deterministic answers which
are coming out of the AI.
So our entire course is actually going to
be that. We are going to look at
What AI tool is available first?
what it is doing.
So this is going to be the pattern. Okay,
we'll start with every phase of SDLC.
We'll start with requirements.
We are going to 1st look at what is
requirements engineering or what
generally they do there and what AI is
going to help there.
What are the risks it brings in?
Can we trust that risk?
Or how do we reduce the risk?
Or how do we eliminate the risk?
What are the guardrails we are going to
build on?
What are the best practices the industry
is practicing to do that?
So this is what we are going to do at
every phase.
So we are going to analyze both the pros
and the cons and we are also going to
come up with solutions,
what can be the best solutions.
And now the solutions part is evolving
because everyone is right now in the
current phase, they are using the AI.
So there might be right now we are
building guardrails.
We are coming up with frameworks.
We are bringing in harness engineering.
There are people who are writing many
guardrails.
There are people who are going with
complete spec driven Development.
So there are many things we are doing to
control,
bring a control to that particular.
phase where we are using AI.
So we are going to discuss all this
probably while we are doing the course.
There might be a lot of changes also
which is coming in because it's a
evolving field.
We will look at what are the aspects of
it. Okay, yes.
Yeah, of course we will look,
when we look at the challenges,
we will look at the utilization costs,
the token problem, token maxing.
How do we reduce tokens?
So we will look at how, what,
how can we optimize this?
All this we will obviously look at.
Okay, going to the responses, I see 23%.
Of them use for writing and refracting
code, 18% use for documentation and test,
20% for debugging.
21% for learning,
11% for planning or breakdown of
requirements, and the 3% for the others.
Yeah. Right.
So I will also share a form later after
the class with all of you,
just to understand a background at where
do most of you work? I mean,
work in the sense what kind of area,
what is your day-to-day work?
so that we can also fine tune our
examples in a more suitable way for
majority,
because always we have diverse crowds
kind of audience.
So we'll see how we can put into buckets
so that we can have examples at all
phases without deviating from what the
courses intend to cover.
Right, so,
so this is the two questions I had.
So now getting into...
What is Software Development Life Cycle
before AI, forget AI came in all that?
When you look at the Software Development
Life Cycle, it is a process.
All those who have done.
computer science degree in your UG,
you would have had this course on
software engineering,
which mostly would have been theoretical
in nature. But obviously,
when you had work,
you would have implemented many parts of
it,
or you would have experienced many parts
of it, right?
So this SDLC, this circle you see here,
there is a planning phase, analysis,
design, implementation, testing,
and integration. This is a very rough,
a very broad level overview of what
Software Development Life Cycle.
Is actually.
Now, in this itself,
there are many evolution which has
happened. This is not,
this phase is not followed as such.
There are so many iterations within this
each phase. Plus,
if you look at each of the roles which
have evolved out for each phase,
we will look at the next slide,
which is on the roles and
responsibilities at each phase, etc.
etc. So planning, analysis, design,
implementation, testing,
and also there is something on
maintenance, etc.
So each of this phase has a certain set
of tasks which has to be completed.
There are a set of responsibilities and
roles which is done by everyone.
And it's not a waterfall model anymore,
right? You finish off one phase,
you close it,
you cannot open that box again.
That's not how it is.
Right, you have an iterative development.
You,
your other system today is flexible that
we can go and change at any go back,
revisit at any phase again,
so I can go in and out. So,
if I'm I completed planning,
I went into analysis.
And I went into design,
but I encountered a few challenges.
I can go back to analysis,
or even I can again go back to
requirements, re-licit, right?
During implementations,
I can come back and change a few things
on design. So that's how I...
iterations have been and we went in for
more agile and iterated Development and
we have a lot of process plus frameworks
which are supporting us in that right.
Yeah, so is the slide shared in Teams? No,
not yet.
I will share it after the class in Teams
as well as in the course page.
Okay,
a few operational things I will cover at
the end.
I'll just talk about a few things on the
course,
a few things on the operational aspects,
plus the evaluation,
all that I'll just cover.
Shopping.
So now coming to the
stSemAIMLstudentsdocs phases,
so one thing I wanted to put right away
in the very first class itself.
We are exploring the evolving landscape
of AI Augmented Software Development Life
Cycle.
Emphasizing that AI will act as an
amplifier of all the phases.
It will amplify the organizational
strengths and it will reduce time,
efforts and reduce the problems, etc.
But we will also have to be very clear
that while there is a sugar rush for
local productivity,
like there are coding assistance, etc.
In the industry or the research which is
there today or the data which we have
today suggests that significant business
value or significant return on investment
or outcome only emerges or will emerge.
Only when...
There is a strong engineering foundations
and clear workflows which are there in
place. So if a, for example,
let's take a company X who already
doesn't have a clear platform engineering
or clear workflows already in place,
AI is not going to come there and do any
magic.
Then.
If there are a few standard pillars which
are required for the software engineering
which is there,
so it's not going to come and replace all
those standard pillars.
When I say standard pillars, the process,
the...
There are a lot of things right from the
code standards we maintain,
the quality gates we have,
the platform engineering,
the workflow approach we have,
all these are pillars. So
AI is going to come and reduce the
weaknesses, problems, etc.
And it is going to be an amplifier for
the existing strengths which are there.
So it's not going to replace or remove
out any of the.
aspects out there.
So that's what the data we have to do.
So a transition from a traditional
development model to a system-oriented
approach that integrates AI across all
phases is what we are going to look at.
And there are,
we are going to look at how that human
validation is required,
how governance is required to ensure
there is stable software,
but there is no technical depth.
And we also will look at metrics.
So the traditional metrics are no more
suitable when it comes to a code which is
developed in assistance with AI. Right?
So we have to measure many other things
also. So we will look at that also.
Okay,
so the point I wanted to put here is we
will be evaluating, we will,
when I say AI Augmented SDLC,
it doesn't mean I will for sure use AI at
all phases or all tasks.
We will evaluate whether AI fits there,
what are the problems and...
If it's right,
we will use it at this point in time.
We will look at both the positives as
well as the negatives when it comes to
applying at every phase.
Okay, now coming to the SDLC phases.
So it starts with the planning phase.
So the primary responsible roles,
product managers, engineering lead,
business stakeholders.
And then we have...
What they basically do,
they start with the initial planning,
they define the scope of the project,
the budgeting, the resources involved,
the high level timelines, etc.
Right,
and then comes the requirements phase,
business analysts, product owners. I mean,
this is a very broad overview, okay?
So I just put it up so that the, the, the,
the model,
it matches with the modular structure.
There are so many other things,
each of them,
each of this can go into an entire course
as well.
But since this is being an introductory
course,
we will look at the most important key
tasks in artifacts. So in requirements,
we detailed it out,
analyzed the requirements that just come,
put it out in terms of software
requirements specifications.
clarify the acceptance criteria with the
different stakeholders, etc.
And then we get into the design phase.
So initial design starts with.
the architecture design,
the database design, the UI-UX design.
You go back to your users,
understand the end users,
you do a little bit of user studies.
So then you come and do the UI-UX design
class, the product design.
Then we go into developing the
Prototypes.
Then, as the implementation phase,
so we write code, perform unit test,
conduct peer code reviews.
Then we also do the integration testing,
regulation testing,
and all kinds of tests.
So while implementation itself,
we will have the CI/CD path set up,
the infrastructure set up.
So we will have our different features
set up. There will be a DevOps engineer,
site reliability engineer who manages the
releases, executes, cut over,
configures production infrastructure,
et cetera. And of course, the maintenance.
new developments, our PRs,
pull request will come in.
We monitor performance,
we see how this can be automated,
observability, can there be time to...
recover from failures,
the meantime to recover from failures,
can it be reduced?
Can incident managements be handled
automatically?
So these are tasks which we look at in
the ops side. So in each of these phases,
this is what is happening.
or this is what happened a few years back.
Now, if you look...
I'm going to ask some questions since all
of you are there in the IT industry.
What do you think they will use here?
What tool they might use here or what for
what AI might be used here?
Just make a random guess.
Or if any of you are business
stakeholders, product managers, et cetera,
you can see,
you can tell probably where do you,
what do you use here.
Microsoft Project usually they use
currently.
Right, OK.
Copilot,
I see Copilot Claude with reasoning. Yes,
that's right.
Any project management tool they might
use, true, is where I work.
Right, yes.
Microsoft, of course,
will pilot everything.
So, second.
Requirements analysis.
Mostly the same set of tools or do we
have anything specific?
Do you think they will probably they can
generate user stories?
They can generate acceptance criteria
from a set of SRS documents, etc.
Right.
GPD, yes.
I'm not out of it for documentation.
Is it OK?
Sirisha has given a new name to me today.
Okay. Design phase.
So what do you think are the tools?
Open spec, yeah, open spec and remote.
So what about design Figma?
Figma has an AI support.
All AI tools will be used with MCP
servers connected, yes.
Anything other than Figma?
For system architectural say as by visual
user interface designs.
Nero.
Lucid chart.
So, are you?
So, draw,
does it have some AI aspect came in?
I know Sigma and Miro had something.
I'm not sure about the others.
Yeah, image, image generator, typeface,
yes, right. So now the most used part,
the implementation.
Codex.
GitHub copilot anti-gravity plot code.
Inself.
Loveable.
Person.
Yes, template.
Right, all these are,
they will use it for writing production
for performance. So now there are,
as I think someone said about MCP,
we will,
we might be using Playwrite and we might
be using MCP servers to connect.
And we will still be generating some.
Or, six and drop, right? Yeah.
So, testing again.
the same set of coding tools plus is
there anything specific other than the
MCP one?
Yeah,
playwright I said MC playwright MCP
videos. ODM.
Yes, so all these names are different,
the tools are different,
but basically we are leveraging a model.
And we, there is a on top of the model,
there is an engineering which has been
done.
That's what they call it as hardness.
And they are providing it with a specific
feature to us, right?
So that's what we are going to look at,
what it is.
in the course. So we will check,
we will actually check what is best at
each phase and we will try to use,
but majorly for demonstrations, etc.
we will stick to Copilot,
GitHub Copilot and Claude is what I'm
thinking.
But let me see if there are any other
interesting tools can be brought in also
at each of these places.
Now a few important things.
These are some of the...
Ohh.
Realities which we have as of today, so...
We'll discuss these are four things that
just come up from one of the surveys.
So, this is from P.W.C.,
the right agent D.S.D.L.C. in practice,
so it's a publication which has come.
So, AI work is surging.
So, I'm talking about the data part.
On Gitar,
AI work is surging on the Gitar while the
global Development community is expanding.
And.
In 2024, I think, or 2025, starting,
I don't exactly remember,
but this is the time when Python overtook
JavaScript for the first time.
Total projects on GitHub with 25% growth.
Um...
And there have been many public Gen.
AI projects with 90% year on year growth.
And Python overtakes JavaScript.
So this is the first headline we have,
which we are looking at.
So,
this has why this has occurred: one is
velocity.
Contributions to Gen.
AI projects jumped in 2024 and then a 98%
increase happened in the number of
projects overall.
And for one is velocity with which the
tools can work.
They shift tool chains and patterns
faster than traditional release cycles
can absorb.
Second is the AI literate developer base
because all of us are trying out
something or the other. We are curious.
And we also have the fear of missing our
the form of aspect, yes, so all of us try.
So, AI literate developers face.
has increased. Everyone has able,
AI has democratized coding and
development. So this child,
this changes who builds software,
how quickly they can learn via AI,
et cetera. So because in my poll also,
I saw 21% of us use it for learning.
That's very true. I don't anymore go or.
Or depend on any web searches or any
other documentations, etc.
If I want a quick learning aspect,
I depend on AI, of course, right?
So we use it for learning,
so that because it speeds the learning
part.
And Stack Drift Python rise to number one
language and notebook usage has gone.
I reflect.
that we are no more just building thread
based app. What is a thread based app?
Like create, read, update and delete.
Like those were the most of our apps,
our web applications or mobile
applications initially had.
Right, we have a database layer,
and most of our applications have that
that basic operations,
and we have an interface,
we have a management.
So that's how it was.
And JavaScript was the most suitable one
for such kind of building of apps,
et cetera.
But with Python taking up,
it reflects that we are having more ML or
agentic work in our applications.
Maybe there are more AI features in each
and every application coming in.
So velocity.
talent and the stack drifting.
That's what we take away from the first
headline here.
Coming to the second one,
the Stack Overflow.
AI tools are now mainstream.
Eighty-four percent use or plan to use
them.
And that's what this the detail says,
and fifty-one percent of professional
developers use them daily.
But.
Most teams still avoid AI for.
High risk SDLC steps.
Hi,
this is actually this high-risk SDLC
steps is like given by the Stack Overflow
Development Survey 2025.
They have given a quote saying that AI is
in daily use,
yet trust and scope limits remain.
Because we are not yet have the
confidence to apply AI at all phases or
hand over the most impactful tasks.
to it because we don't have the
confidence yet or AI has not gained the
confidence yet.
And what are the drivers for this?
is the confidence is there because the
governance gap developers report lower
positive sentiments because the tools
struggle on complex tasks or they had a
few problems while they were using
because of that they in the surveys also
they have.
not confident and on high risk tasks,
et cetera. And the resistance,
as I told one of you had a question,
like where it is most useful, right?
I don't know whether it's most useful,
but I'm sure where all of us have that
little hesitance to apply is on the
deployment and monitoring.
The resistance is highest there because
anything goes wrong,
it directly impacts our revenue,
it directly impacts our productionized
softwares, etc.
So deployment and monitoring is where the
resistance is high to use AI tools.
76% of the people said that we are not
going to use it or don't plan to use it
in the near future.
Project planning is where, again, 69%,
you have to,
maybe you have to redesign controls and
quality again.
So the governance gap is the first factor.
We don't have the confidence in that.
Daily usage of blank.
Um.
That is,
you are already doing a task which you
are well aware of. It requires you, uh,
it, it, you want to use AI to.
Do some.
maybe a little bit of assistance to you,
accelerate your work,
work as an amplifier, etc.
That is where major of us are using.
Faster onboarding, fewer blank pages.
So you can easily shift from junior to
senior levels, etc.
So, talent.
is that AI is often quite highly used for
writing, debugging, testing,
but not for the high risk production
gates, sign of models, et cetera.
Though it is adoption is daily,
there is a lack of trust later.
So one of our aim in this course will
also be to look at how that trust can be
increased.
What kind of quality gates or guardrails
can be put in?
So that we can trust it for all kinds of..
.
aspects aspect, right?
So the third one, this is my.
Most favorite also.
80%, sorry, not 80%.
This experiment which was done,
you can go read this report also.
I think the entire report is there,
the meta report.
Yeah.
There were first initially,
there's an updated version of the report
also, in 2026, I think. Initially,
they took 16 experienced maintainers of
their own reports and asked them to use
AI tools. And it had reported that.
It had made them 19% slower on this real
day-to-day task.
So all of us are believing that AI is
going to come and amplify and reduce time
for.
But when it was given to experience there,
a set of people who were recruited and
did a survey and testing,
they were initially having the problem,
90% slower with early 2025 AI tools.
Now it will be not that slow.
The.
For 2 reasons, one,
the tools have also developed well,
and we also have a cubed ourselves,
we would have learned how to use tools,
we have an in-built understanding, etc.,
counting in, etc. But...
The picture this gives us expectation is
not going to be equal to reality,
at least yet. OK,
the expectations equal to reality will
come.
only when we have the trust and when we
have tested it, right? So here, AI speed,
whatever the speed AI is bringing in or
the velocity AI is bringing in.
Is fine,
but it also that speed also requires us
to do something additional, right?
Prompt iteration, verification, fixing,
write code, right?
Not these are all not linear things,
so if I can write a piece of a function,
if I'm asked to write a small function.
or I'm asked to build,
let's take a very simple task like login
page. If I'm an expert, it takes me.
say 10 minutes to do that or I can do
even lesser time than that.
If the AI aspect which I'm going to bring
in is going to take more time.
that the prompt I have to build,
the verification I have to do,
the fixing later I have to do,
all the iterations I have to run.
If it's going to be taking more time than
what I have been doing already,
that is where it is going to slow down
the existing productivity of.
Thank you, sir.
Right.
So it's not that we should not use AI for
our day-to-day or things which are we are
export at,
but we have to look at ways how this time
can be reduced and how we also have to
consider the training or the initial
phase where we do the migration,
the initial learning.
of understanding of the AI as we bring in.
The second most factor.
Is only cost and quality.
The availability,
like some of you were asking about tokens,
right?
So is it really worth the number of
tokens for AI to do it or still I can do
it myself? That's also a question, right?
So this I will this report I will get
into it a little more in detail because I
think I have not read the latest version.
There is a 2026 follow up report also for
this. I will get into that a little daily,
but the take away is speed gains are not
guaranteed. We might we might expect it.
Maybe the product manager might think,
okay, with just one prompt,
the feature can be ready,
but there might be a lot of internal
things which might not come out.
And the last one is...
on the AI native products from the third
party APIs.
80% of the companies permit third party
AI tools and 18% of developers,
they are already integrating AI into
their products.
and AI is shifting us from assistance to
capability.
Um...
So more products embedding AI means there
will be more agentic workflows,
more non-determinism,
and there has to be more runtime
evaluation loops.
SDLC must include model life cycle and
observability.
So here you are using a third party tool.
80% of the organizations,
they permit third party tools means there
should be proper governance,
standard practices, policies,
Uh, which then we have our own.
gates or quality gates based on how we
check that.
Right.
And.
The tooling and the ID, the ecosystem,
the vendor ecosystem also should.
work.
They should also standardize around AI
features.
Now with Visual Studio Code thing,
there is no.
A option to add a copilot or.
a plot code there.
It's not practically possible for us to
keep juggling between different tools,
right? So there should be options and for,
they should also standardize around AI
features,
compressing certain roles while elevating
evaluation, safety risks, et cetera.
So, Software Development is there.
AI adoption is very high.
36% of software roles use AI for at least
quarter of their task.
So this is the area compared to all the
other aspects. The highest is...
In Software Development.
But...
We also have to use 36% use only for
certain of their tasks.
4% use it extensively across all of their
work.
And if you look at all of the work that
has come,
it's more augmentative in nature and not
outrightly placed.
So, that...
So this is like the title card I can put
here, right?
So that's why it's AI Augmented SDLC.
It's not AI SDLC. Like we are not,
AI is not replacing the software
engineering there.
It is only augmenting the software
engineering.
So, 57%, at least not yet. Okay,
tomorrow I'm not sure. It might,
AI might replace that is software
engineering and it might have an AI
driven completely automated development
life cycle. But
At this point in time,
it's mostly Augmented and not an outright
replacement. So here,
velocity plus cost is a major thing.
Partial AI adoption speeds up the routine
task, but still mixed usage means.
mixed usage conveys that we still have
many things to fix there.
And how do you bring?
The hybrid workflows where you have the
AI augmenting plus you have the human
developers as well.
So you have to look at the collaboration,
the human in the loop aspects plus the
collaborative ones.
It should not be just handoffs between
teams.
How do we have a collaboration between
human developers and AI tools?
So there are many things which will come
there. So,
but we are very clear at this point in
time on one aspect,
that it is mostly augmentation in nature
and not automation completely.
Because we are having multiple
checkpoints, multiple gates,
human in the loop checkpoints, et cetera,
to just check off certain things.
So human decision making is still the
crucial or remains central to this
adoption. So this is what the metrics,
all these metrics tell us.
So, so far in these two slides,
I've been talking about a few data to
give you all of you a picture where are
we at today. Okay,
so we are not completely relying on AI or
we don't have anyone who's
not touching AI.
So we are in the transition and this is
the status.
This is the reality we are in doing.
So we have a lot of avenues or problems
we can take up and work and we can see
how it transitions into more productivity.
Also,
we have to understand the risk involved.
In this.
Entire.
Using the AI aspects,
so this is a metaphor I I just.
Liked very much.
So you have a high speed car that you
want to drive and you want to utilize
that to the maximum.
But if you have to drive only in a road
with traffic jam,
you cannot use that particular car or you
having that car is not going to benefit
Yeah.
If you are entire,
if you are driving in a traffic jam,
you have a certain limit with which you
can go.
Just because your car can go to a speed,
we cannot drive that way in the traffic
jam, right?
So that's what is the status we have.
today.
The velocity at which AI is building,
we have a lot of code getting generated
and the developer is able to produce a
lot of code.
But...
How does it fit into our existing systems
which we are already having?
So this picture is an example of it.
So AI generation happens faster.
We have the velocity, the volume,
a lot of volume coming in here at great
speed, but
Here we have a few flaky tests.
We have our legacy docs who still don't
have much.
aspects there.
The product AI capabilities are exploding,
but organizations are only seeing minimal
productivity gains.
So this side you can see the capabilities
are increasing to a vast extent, but
Here,
we are having only minimal productivity
gains.
So, how do we fix this?
Right, so this only when we fix this,
we can have a good deployment value.
Otherwise, there's no use of having this.
or improving this again and again.
So this is where our work is going to
come in. So now one question I will ask.
How much of a time a software developer
will spend on average in a day in writing
code?
Let's take a day, one working day.
How much time do you think a software
developer will spend in writing code?
To us, OK, 30%, OK.
Two to three hours.
For us.
So this all of you are putting numbers
considering a working day, right?
Nine hours or our,
I mean our official working hours or you
are considering.
Twenty-four hours.
So,
I hope this two hours is on a working
hours based on working hours.
Yeah, so.
That's why I said on paper working hours,
because when deadlines are approaching,
it's never the on paper working hours,
right?
Yeah, three to four hours of actual work.
OK,
so what do you think the rest of the time
the Software engineer does?
apart from writing code or
So when I say debugging,
that's also writing code only.
So you are fixing the errors in the code.
That's something we can take it as
writing code itself.
Core feature work, I, I,
instead of coding,
and I will put it like core feature work,
you actually do coding, debugging,
etcetera.
Eight.
Unit testing.
Right, Scrum ceremonies, collaboration,
analysis, analysis, testing,
documentation.
Planning meeting.
Internal QA troubleshooting.
Development.
Yes, peer review of core, of course, yes.
So that's a 40-60 split is what they are
generally referring to. So 40%,
most developers typically spend around
40% of their time on core feature work.
Which includes coding, debugging,
et cetera,
and while remaining 60% is consumed for a
collection of non-coding activities and
cognitive.
understanding and drain.
So when I say non-coding activity,
the 60%.
They spend a significant portion of the
day learning, gathering knowledge,
searching for outdated information on
documentations,
trying to understand a legacy system or
microservices function which is running,
how it's working.
And context switching,
even in context switching,
frequent interruptions that we have a
meeting, we have a scrum call,
we are shifting,
some other PR has a priority today.
So we need to jump between different
tools, tasks, and meetings.
So that also creates a mental.
overhead that breaks the focus.
So context switching itself,
they say some amount of time goes in that.
waiting and coordination,
waiting for pipelines to finish PR
reviews.
General fiction.
Generally,
the friction with other teams and
dependencies.
coordinating with them,
conveying requirements, etc.
And a massive amount of time is spent
simply trying to understand and pull the
mental model of the entire software
architecture or the distributed
architecture before the code.
So you try to understand and have a
complete idea of your system before you
start.
writing your code, right?
So the managing the complexity and the
cognitive load, that's one aspect.
And of course,
our regular administrative tasks is where
you spend, like updating Jira tickets,
manual status updates,
or various synchronous meetings you
attend,
all those administrative tasks and
ceremonies.
And a small amount of time is also goes
in configuration errors,
setting up the configuration,
complex deployment processes, et cec.
So now all the tasks I listed, right?
That 60%, we don't have many.
AI tools to do that because there is so
much of context. It's our individual.
I only if I build a clone of myself and
keep it that 60% can be replaced.
So majority of the 40% is what we can.
Organizations at this point in time are
only using AI to speed up that 40% of the
work.
So, 60% of the time,
when the real friction is something which
we can look,
which we are still not looked at much
from an aspect. So,
this I'm talking in terms of only
developer,
so one of you maybe who are not in
development, but...
on QA or on the DevOps side or etc.
You can even list down the other set of
activities you do apart from your core
feature work.
And you can say how much of that AI can
replace, etc.
Right.
So.
So still there is a lot we can explore
the other aspects,
the organizations of the software
engineering as a.
community and as a process itself,
they can look at greatest opportunity for
improvement,
reducing the other aspects of that 60% as
well.
Okay, so I think I have...
I mean,
these are the major things I wanted to
cover today.
So this is what we will go into our next,
from our next classes probably.
So the traditional development cycle goes
into planning, design, development,
testing, deployment, maintenance.
with human across every stage.
So the AI is going to augment each of
these faces.
And we are also going to look at how this
can be more autonomous in nature.
What are the risks involved?
Can be completely automated or it's only
going to be augmented?
Um...
So these are some things we are going to
look at.
So, these two...
are the major questions which we are
going to answer.
In this particular course.
For all the benefits AI is bringing in,
it is introducing new constraints on the
technical, organizational,
as well as cultural levels.
So how AI is reshaping every stage and
how to adapt for AI driven delivery at
every phase is what these are the two
questions we are going to find answers in
this particular.
Course.
OK, so with that.
I present the course description.
This is as part this is as approved by
the university,
plus you have this in your.
post handout which has been uploaded to
the post page as well. So we will...
look at evolution of SDNC.
Basically in one line,
if you ask me what this course is about,
how do we deliver software with AI
acceleration under AI acceleration?
So that's the description.
So how do we approach it?
We are approaching it in a modular
structure.
So we start looking at what are the
existing SDLC models,
how they have evolved,
how AI is bringing in and changing the
aspects of them.
So what are the risks it brings in,
what the impact AI brings into each of
these phases.
What are the interaction patterns?
How do we interact with AI at every phase?
What are the quality gates we have to
build?
What are the validation strategies we
have to build at every step in the AI
driven life cycle? Where should we have
human.
We cannot have human in the loop decision
points everywhere.
Then there's no point in improving the
time with AI, right?
So where should we have a human in the
loop decision points where we can go for
a computational tool,
where we go for an inferential tool?
How do you?
The moment you click the prompt and the
output comes,
the code is not AI code anymore,
it's your code.
So we are accountable for it.
Though it comes out of an LLM or an AI
coding agent, the moment it comes out,
it is our code.
KOHAD.
So how do you take accountability,
ownership in this continuously changing
systems? How we can feed...
forward as well as how the feedback loops
can come in from different reporting
tools to ensure that the same error
doesn't occur again.
And metrics wise also we cannot keep
looking at the same metrics which are no
more applicable to us in certain ways.
So we have to identify what are the new
metrics.
We have to look at reliability,
not just speed.
Earlier time to market was one of the
major concerns, but now time to market,
because code is getting generated faster,
time to market can be reduced,
can be reduced to a larger extent,
but are we shipping reliable products,
stabilized products is what we have to
also look at. So that's what.
Is a rough description on the objective
wise?
So the same thing which is written in
terms of the objectives,
understand the evolution of Software
Development Life Cycle.
Development an understanding of AI
fundamentals,
explore practical applications of AI
tools across all phases,
and understand the need and learn to
define governance mechanisms, strategies,
decision points, etc.
I'll take a quick break here.
So a five-minute break.
We come back and look at the modular
structure,
and I'll talk about the evaluation
components and a few operational aspects,
and then we will...
Take up all questions and answers,
we can have some discussion time,
and we'll close for today. OK, yeah,
I'll talk about the books as well.
Let's take a very quick break for 10
minutes. So at 7.10,
so we'll be back by 7.15.
OK, so.
Let's continue.
So the entire course is divided into 8
modules. So that's what you see.
The detailed modular structure is given
to you in the course handout,
which is there in the course page.
So the first modules talks about the
foundations and the
shift basically.
So we look at evolution of different SDLC
models from waterfall agile to continuous
AI augmentation and different phases and
what are the risks it brings in.
That is the change velocity,
the technical depth.
hallucination risks, architectural drift,
etc.
And we'll also look at the economics part
of it,
the cost and economics of AI augmentation,
token problems, etc.
Second module is SAURAV.
It's a little deviating from our flow.
It is some basic understanding of AI we
need to use these tools.
We will not get into too much technical,
but some basic understanding of AI.
What is a foundation model? What is today?
What is a transformer?
What is a large language model?
What do I mean by tokenization tokens?
What is context engineering or context
window? How do we manage AI?
deterministic,
non-deterministic output and
deterministic software systems and some
prompt strategies also.
And a little bit of introduction to agent
workflows.
So the second module is all AI knowledge
we need to use it in SDLC.
That is what we will have a fundamental
model.
So there we will, there will be more,
mostly I will try to cover overview
without getting into the math and the
technical aspects,
which is required to create those models,
but just from an end user perspective of
how do we use all these models, etc.
A little bit on MCP also we will cover,
but not into technical detail.
So from third module,
we will start with each phase.
So third module is on requirements and
design.
So we will start with the requirements
gathering,
the risk involved in bringing in AI,
where do we,
where can we build the guard rails?
Then we will look at design. Again,
how do we...
approach spec driven development.
How do we design and then generate
architectural decision records?
And how do we prototype?
How do we use AI to generate prototypes?
And a little bit on threat modeling as
well to ensure security.
For our design, etcetera.
So that will be requirements and design
phase.
Then the coding and refractoring phase.
So we will look at popular patterns,
autonomous coding agents,
how they are used,
how coding agents are used in code
refractoring, and how we can
Detect problems, bugs, code smells,
how legacy migration or legacy code can
be migrated,
and versioning and documentation.
The first module will be on testing.
So how do you generate test for your code
which has been already available?
How do you do automatic code reviews?
There are a few problems,
circular validation.
And then there are.
certain human checkpoints we would need.
So we look at all those in module 5.
Module 6 will be on the deployment
release.
A part, so we will see how.
the infrastructure as a code or other
codes can be generated using AI.
How we can...
Automate the release management process,
the deployment strategies.
What are the options we are available? So,
as I mentioned earlier, that's a little...
very less explored area.
Though there are the coding part and the
documentation part, which are still used,
we have to look at ways in which.
AI can be leveraged there.
And Module 7 will talk about.
governance.
the control points, the ownership,
we'll also look at a few compliance
aspects there.
And Module 8 is how do you feedback into
the system?
How do you use your data,
the elementary data available at
different aspects,
and what are the metrics which will
change from the traditional Dora metrics
which I've been using to more developer?
related metrics or other newer metrics.
And how do we manage the entire code base
is what we will look at.
So every module will follow a same
pattern.
We will look at the AI assistance plus
the pros and cons, as I said earlier.
And we will also have a considerable
number of fans on
course. We'll see how the lab sessions,
maybe we'll schedule separate lab
sessions or we will see how this can be
blended with the class work itself.
A detailed plan I will give it to you
very soon.
Coming to the...
Books to be followed.
We don't have much MOOCs which cover all
these topics at this point in time,
but I have given a few references which
touch upon certain chapters of our course.
So we will use
The.
Generative AI for Software Development
book as a general,
because it has all the faces covered to a
minimal level,
which is given in your course handout,
the textbook one.
And AI engineering,
building applications with foundation
models, that understanding is required.
So module 2 will refer to that AI
engineering book by Chip Hoden.
So all these names, book references,
details are given. But majorly,
we will be referring to web resources
only.
at this point in time.
So we will majorly refer to many
technology podcasts, Tech ThoughtWorks,
Radar,
and there is a Software Engineering
Institute of Cargie Mellon University.
So they have a AI Augmented Software
Engineering to separate the research
track. So we will look at some papers,
some publications from them,
and we will also refer to many technology
radar podcasts from ThoughtWorks and
major such organizations like
Netflix and Uber.
So all these organizations who are
pioneer in using AI for their lives,
SDLC life cycles,
they also have good engineering blogs,
which they publish often.
So we will refer to those experts.
And as and when there are new books
coming in,
we will be able to adopt from their
experts. So
Each of the end of the class,
I will have a reference section which I
will publish with the details of the web
links and the details there,
which you can collectively use for all
your references.
Active.
So that song in books.
Coming to the last,
but the most important one as well.
is the evaluation part.
So,
all of you are new to the entire program,
so let me explain a little in detail. So,
we have a continuous evaluation system.
So we have two examinations which will
happen.
One is after the 8th contact session.
which is on the mid-semester.
We call it as a mid-semester examination
or EC2. EC2 means evaluation component 2.
So that will happen after 8 weeks,
where you will go to a physical on-site
centers and write.
of the examination for two hours.
So that is the mid-semester,
which will be for 30 marks.
It's a closed book examination.
And then...
Ohh, OK.
Request you want?
Why tonight?
Remote all parties.
Can we lib?
Then at the end of the course,
after 16 contact sessions are over,
we will have the final comprehensive
examination, which is for 40%.
That is an open book examination.
That will be for 2 1/2 hours.
You will write in a...
platform which the WILP division will
brief you and orient you on the platform
and other details etc.
So now this is 30 plus 40,
70 marks will go in that.
And then you will have the remaining 30
marks,
which is called as the EC1 components,
which will happen throughout where we
will do it in the course page,
in your course page in the Takshida LMS.
which we are using.
You have a course page,
you have the handout,
all of you are part of it.
I can see many of you have already logged
in and checked it,
but there are a few who might have not
logged in.
So you can also log in and check.
So it has,
that is where we will be administering
the quizzes, assignments, et cetera,
and all the PPT materials.
also will be posted there.
So quiz one and two will be for 5% each.
So there will be MCQ questions,
15 to 20 MCQ questions. You can log in.
So the quiz will be open for, say,
one week of time.
And then you can log in to the start the
quiz. But once you start the quiz,
there will be a time limit around 30
minutes or 20 minutes,
depending on the time.
But in that one week,
you can take it any time you want.
So the quiz.
will be there.
It will be auto evaluated 5 marks.
This one will be done before the mid sem,
and quiz two will be done in the next
half after the mid sem,
then assignment one and two again.
Similarly, we will have one assignment.
It will be a continuing assignment only,
because this course requires a full
end-to-end understanding,
so it will be a continuing assignment.
But we will have the first phase of the
assignment before the mid sem and we will
do the next phase of the assignment after
the mid sem.
So the assignment will be mostly coding
in nature. That is not only coding.
We will do whatever we are talking in
class.
We will do a complete end to end product.
Development.
deployment,
we will see if it's possible with the
infrastructure we have, we will do it,
otherwise we will skip that,
but we can deploy it in our local systems
also.
But we will do an end-to-end lifecycle of
a particular software product.
That's what we will do in this course for
the assignment.
For the comprehensive exam,
which is open book,
you are allowed to take the faculty
provided slides.
But the faculty provided slides,
you don't take printout now because there
is a watermark team which the team will
give you details about.
So it has to be watermarked and provided
to you so you can take the print out in
the last.
after your 11th or 12th sessions,
once the dfdf is uploaded.
At this point of time,
you use it for your preparation and
studying alone.
Apart from the faculty provided slides,
they will also allow you to take the
books
But other than the books and the faculty
provided slides,
there will not be any other AI generated
notes or.
Question, answer,
manual or solutions or any kind of other
generated information will not be allowed.
So I will try to make the slides as
elaborate as possible so you can have all
the information in the slides as well.
And all the class materials will be
provided in the eLearn course page,
plus the Ms. TEAMS files folder as well,
so you can use them for your preparation.
And the coding, there is a coding,
there is no coding language we are not
going to restrict.
There will be a problem statement defined
for you,
so you will do every phase for that
particular problem statement.
We will start with the requirements
design.
coding, implementation, testing, etc.
That's how it will go.
So you have to decide the coding language
for your assignment.
For the mid sem, we will see,
I will let you know.
Ideally,
we should be covering till the coding and
refracting module 4.
There will be one end assignment as a
whole will be an end-to-end assignment,
but there will be two phases of
evaluation.
So, but you can take it as assignment one,
total one assignment, 20 marks.
Okay, so yes, there will be,
there is a AI based tool which is used
for question paper and assignment
generation. But as there are,
though it is a tool,
we still have human in the loop.
It's not automatic.
So faculty members as well as instructors.
have an option to change what is suitable
for the class so it's not completely
automated.
So we will take support of AI to do that,
but still it is a question paper and
assignment prepared by the faculty only.
So group assignment or individual, I will.
I have to think about it.
Group assignments have not worked very
well in the past because of various time
zones and geographical locations each of
you are available.
So we will go with individual assignments
only.
So that's majorly on the evaluation part.
More details I will give it to you later.
The book references are there in the
course handout.
I will share the handout for those who
have not.
Seen it in.
So this is the course handout that's
there in your.
E-learn page.
So, you have the textbooks references.
I'll keep adding references at the end of
each slide also,
but this is your complete reference for
the list of topics.
A few information on the evaluation lab,
etc. So,
this lab is what we will combine into an
assignment evaluation, OK?
Yes.
I will upload this slide to the course
page.
Yeah, textbook information,
everything is there in the course and up
as we.
No, closed,
you can use textbooks to prepare for the
examinations.
Closed book in the sense you are not,
you cannot take the books for the exam.
So you can either refer the books or the
slides for preparation wise.
That's up to you.
But we don't have a complete textbook
which has all the contents.
So the flow is something which you have
to stick to the slides only.
But content-wise,
you can explore many other resources as
well.
Okay, so any other questions?
If there are no other questions,
then I would like to wind up for today.
Thank you all for joining.
So from next class,
we will start with each module.
E.
I didn't understand the Krishna's
question.
Closed book meals.
I mean, you can hear my voice now.
So my intention of asking is closed book
Yeah, yes.
system and open book system means like
open and I mean for EC3 evaluation,
we can take the slides for the exam
center and we can use the reference.
Yeah.
for the solution of the problem statement,
right?
So but for EC2 slides which we are
discussing in the class that we can't
take it, right? That's what I'm asking.
Yes, for EC2, no materials can be taken.
It will be a,
when we say closed book examination,
you will have to just write with the
question paper and you will have to
answer. For the open book examination,
you are allowed to take your slides and
books.
Okay, so that's what like I was asking.
So the concepts of the contents which
Shuchi.
were explained in the task followed by
the slides, everything,
if we prepare them,
will it be able to cope up with the
closed book exam, right?
That's what I want to ask, ma'am.
Yes.
That's correct. Yes.
For the comprehensive exam,
whatever books are mentioned in the
course handout,
plus the PPT slides alone will be allowed.
Yeah.
Okay, thank you all.
I'm looking forward for the session.
If there are any questions,
you can reach out to me through my e-mail.
Thank you, Naveen.
Or you can use the TEAMS as well.
Thank you all.